i rank the good doctor as the second
most accurate medical drama of all time
and then abc gave me an exclusive first
look at the season five premiere which
premieres monday september 27th 10 9
central on abc let's see what dr sean
murphy's up to this season and huge
thank you to abc for sponsoring this
video
shawn robert oh look at them getting
married everyone's suited up oh storming
coming
[Music]
remember those who are diagnosed with
autism spectrum disorder are susceptible
to really loud sounds they hear them
louder the processing of auditory
stimuli is different it can be very
uncomfortable so much so that they can
have a panic attack just because of a
loud sound or other external stimuli
definitely the first
gentleman to wear earplugs in the middle
of his wedding
what's wedding like norms is there bad
luck if it's thundering and pouring
during your wedding or is that like good
luck like a pigeon pooping on you
oh no
hi
i had a great time last night me too
wanna go grab some breakfast i gotta get
to the hospital oh don't do that doctor
thing i gotta get to the hospital if
you're having a person spend the night
eat breakfast enjoy each other's company
plan for it perhaps i should let you go
no no i was uh hoping for a little
excitement this morning mmm spicy
just give me two minutes to make this go
away yeah
whoa
so much romance and the episode just
started some shortness of breath
occasional blurred vision and headaches
and this morning my urine was foamy is
she pregnant cause that could be a
problem any blood in your urine a little
you take 20 milligrams of written alley
a day for my adhd blurred vision and
headaches can be side effects from
redland would you be willing to stop
your medication for a couple of days see
if they're causing any of your symptoms
i'll refer any complaints about my
behavior to you what's interesting to me
is she's having a wide range of symptoms
outside of blurry vision and headaches
that warrant further investigation
whenever you're trying to decide whether
or not it's due to a medication side
effect you're trying to rule out any
organic causes then you could try doing
things with medications but jumping to
medications right off the bat unless
it's like a really well-known side
effect then it's only that one symptom
doesn't usually happen we're gonna run
some labs and do a ct of your kidneys
let's say the foamy urine could be a
sign of kidney stones the first test you
would do there wouldn't be a ct scan
unless the patient was having other
symptoms like back pain so i would do
like a urine dipstick test make sure
that we have the presence of blood there
then send it out for a urine microscopy
see if there's crystals there and then
what you can do is you do a 24-hour
urine collection
to see the total amount of the calcium
oxalate or uric acid or whatnot in the
urine
renal pelvis looks clean you sound
disappointed but what's that on the
right kidney
could be a mess she needs a kidney
biopsy interesting for conditions like
this we usually page the interventional
radiologist as well as the oncologist to
decide if we see suspicious features on
the scan there's also conditions like
polycystic kidney disease which you just
develop a lot of cysts in your kidneys
potentially leading to needing a kidney
transplant or even
having it become a fatal disease
have you always had fat ankles
rude only if the answer is yes if the
answer is no it's a symptom edema uh in
the lower extremities for a young person
could be a sign of proteinuria which
means she's going into kidney failure
she could have a nephrotic syndrome she
has blood in her urine so she could have
like fsg caused by hiv there's there's a
lot of possibilities here are you
overwhelmed planning the wedding because
park and lim thought you might be
overwhelmed
no i don't know i've got it it's gonna
be great oh great there should be a term
called weld what if there's not too much
but there's a lot weld nice exposure of
the right tonsil visibility can be tough
with kids that's true when you're doing
any kind of procedure in their
oropharyngeal space it's sometimes hard
to get a visual there's a firm irregular
mouse in this tonsil
tonsil stone did that to pathology i i
didn't quite see it it looked like a
tonsil stone i hope it's not a tumor of
any sort riley's throat it's still
really bothering him we had to remove
additional tissue because your son's
tonsils showed signs of cancerous cells
riley has cancer the cancer on your
son's tonsil is cervical cancer
interesting cervical cancer in the sense
of hpv induced cancer he got it from you
he was exposed to your cancerous cells
in the birth canal which he likely
inhaled jackson may also have been
exposed during birth we need to scan
both you we definitely need to find out
her pap smear results because that is
how we screen for cervical cancer the
human papillomavirus hpv has certain
high-risk subtypes that predispose you
to the development of cancer that's why
we recommend patients to get vaccinated
against hpv in order to prevent the
virus thereby preventing the cancer it's
actually one of the only vaccines that
we have that prevents cancer the pet
scan shows increased metabolic activity
in the mother's uterus and the sun's
trachea oh no they both have cancer
yeah that's that's the terrible part
about human papilloma virus they can
cause cancer there in the anode genital
region oral cavity in the oral mucosa as
seen with this child and then it gets
spread if it is advanced your cancer is
quite advanced those cervical cancers
are detected early with regular pap
smears i this is a really important
point not only should you be getting
regular visits with your doctor for a
whole host of reasons but you should be
making sure that your pap smears are up
to date from the age of 21. it means
that from the age of 21 you start
getting them every three years once you
hit the age of 30 the guidelines now
change and say that we should do pap
smears plus hpv co-testing which means
we also check for hpv at the same time
and if both are negative at that time
you could spread it out to every five
years
endoscopic mucosal tracheal resection
if jackson's tumor was seated via
exposure during birth which is a very
reasonable assumption then we can
reasonably assume that it is localized
endoscopic resection should allow for a
recovery of days instead of weeks
talk to the mother but talk to the
surgical team why didn't they figure
that out shawn is a super surgeon
you're at the mass
as a wide base
no easy way to loop my snare around it
oh no is it is it oh no pulsating is it
a blood vessel is it a round is it
surrounding a blood vessel it has a
major arterial feeder from his aorta and
we can't
remove it from this angle without
risking a massive bleed the interesting
part about tumors is that they go
through a process called angiogenesis
which is the formation of new blood
vessels they do this in order to keep
themselves alive and to feed themselves
to grow and in those cases you have to
perform an open surgery where you
actually go in and separate the blood
vessel carefully while making sure that
you're having adequate blood supply
throughout the rest of the body abort
the surgery
i think i know what they're gonna do and
i'm not a surgeon i'm gonna try and
predict it i think they're gonna do a
radical coil embolization where they're
gonna go in through either a vein or the
femoral vein put in a catheter and
they're gonna embolize it like as if
it's an aneurysm
dude are you serious hey hey
i would like to um
make a toast
i have never ever seen you as happy
as you are
right now with leah he does look happier
like when i think about the first
episode of the good doctor that i
watched on this channel he looks much
happier here
some ups and downs a little bit like a
roller coaster okay you guys have
managed it
so well
a whole lot better than i have
is that funny
but here's to
many many many
years of
of happiness
at least two maybe three
[Music]
what is that where you make a relevation
from revelation of that caliber what are
you doing that was
viscerally painful to watch dr lim
excuse me who are you and what are you
doing in my operating room i'm sailing
morrison what are you doing there you're
not surgically prepared to be there it's
dangerous for all parties involved
please page dr anderson have him come
get his patient or security
[Music]
oh i feel
[Music]
something's wrong stop
what causes kidney lesions shortness of
breath swollen ankles and heart
irregularities uh
amyloid deposits a tumor that secretes
some sort of hormone every time we get
close to doing the biopsy on this woman
something
doc blocks us unless
look at her blood work
she said she'd stop her meds but her
ritalin level today is over double when
she came in that could cause her heart
irregularities i could she is
[Music]
what this is like out of this world it
doesn't happen but it could happen click
here to check out a full playlist of all
my good doctor reactions and don't
forget to check out the season premiere
of the good doctor september 27th 10 9
central on abc huge thanks to abc for
sponsoring this video and as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]